the latest confrontations between
israeli forces and palestinians near the
al-aqsa mosque compound in occupied east
jerusalem
sunday was the first day since the
beginning of the jewish passover
celebrations when non-muslims could
visit the compound
hundreds of jews did so with israeli
forces guarding them neither were
welcome
we were forced out of the mosque after
the dawn prayer then settlers started to
enter
after we saw two groups of them we
started to chant and the police tried to
detain me
israeli police said that palestinians
had gathered stones and put up
barricades to block the jewish groups
from arriving and that they remove
protesters to restore order
the palestinian red crescent reported
injuries to 10 people
the al-aqsa mosque compound is islam's
third holiest place it's also revered by
jews as the site of the original temple
and along with tourists national
zionists visit it regularly
those visits are always a source of
tension but especially this year with
the muslim holy month of ramadan and
passover coinciding
what's also added to the tension is a
small extremist jewish group calling for
sacrifices in the al-aqsa compound
during passover now that's a call that
they make every year it's something that
the israeli government bans every year
including this one but this time around
it's got more attention from
palestinians who are worried that it
might actually
happen israel captured east jerusalem
where the al-aqsa compound is located in
the 1967 war an occupation that's been a
source of anguish for palestinians since
what happened today is a crime because
we can't enjoy our prayers we can't
enjoy our worship our freedom our holy
sites and we can't feel safe anymore
even in the holy sites we've been coming
to since we were young children and
that's because of the occupation
israeli forces also arrested two
palestinians for throwing rocks at buses
with jewish passengers heading to the
old city some were injured only adding
to the tension here
john holman al jazeera occupied east
jerusalem